oral fixations and bullet-riddled ken
dolls the grey man's got it all in the
opening scene of the grey man we're
introduced to cortland gentry court's
been in a florida prison since 1995 with
a lot of years on his sentence still
ahead of him the year is 2003 when agent
donald fitzroy pays him a visit fitzroy
offers court the chance to walk out to
freedom with him at that moment all he
has to do is agree to kill bad guys for
the cia court becomes a disposable
sierra agent his former identity
destroyed much like his future existence
this first sequence is shrouded in
mystery the details of court's past are
cloudy and neither he nor the audience
can trust fitzroy yet but most of all
who's winky and what happened to his
cantina before the movie even shows a
frame on screen an off-screen court is
heard asking if this is about winky's
cantina i didn't have anything to do
with it i like honey buns as much as the
next guy but i'm not gonna gouge your
eye out for one it's certainly a curious
way to start things off and the story
isn't returned to for the rest of the
movie maybe the sequel will finally
explain what happened at winkie's
cantina
right before sierra 6 and sierra 4
square off in the grey man four reveals
that he's also a sierra agent that six
has been sent to kill one of his own
this news doesn't seem to affect six as
he completes his mission by delivering a
fatal blow with his dying breath and to
prove he's authentic four tells how
fitzroy also recruited him to join the
agency we then get a quick flashback of
foreign handcuffs taking bubblegum from
fitzroy as he goes over his file it's
the same offering fitzroy gives six when
they first meet in the florida prison
the flashbacks suggest that fitzroy had
his recruitment process down to a
science if the convict doesn't take the
gum is that a red flag is the offer to
join sierra then rescinded or is it just
a weird habit of fitzroys
before his death sierra 4 informs 6 of
the reason he was sent to kill one of
his own he has information that proves
some of the agency leaders have been
behaving badly one of those leaders is
agency group chief denny carmichael
who's part of the new regime that's
basically forced out the original
leaders who created the sierra program
as four is dying he forces six to take
his necklace which hides a flash drive
with all the intel he needs to bring
down the corrupt leadership six confirms
to carmichael that the target has been
eliminated carmichael knowing what's on
the flash drive is clearly agitated and
he starts asking sixx about his exchange
with the target six never gives the
straight answer but he doesn't flat-out
lie either he simply avoids the
questions and steers the conversation
his way this is a common theme with the
character he's not one to give up
information unnecessarily but he also
isn't a liar the original sierra leaders
fitzroy and margaret cahill are the only
ones who always get a truthful answer
from him whether his lying without lying
is a skill that comes with being a super
secret agent or if it's just who court
is is unclear
during one scene in the grey man suzanne
brewer barges into the men's bathroom to
finish a conversation with carmichael
who's doing his business in the last
stall as carmichael leaves the stall the
pair squabble about his choice to bring
in sociopath lloyd hansen to deal with
sierra 6. carmichael walks over to the
sink during the exchange but neither
soap nor water actually touch his hands
he has a tantrum with paper towels fixes
his shirt cuffs but never runs the water
to be fair the scene cuts before he
leaves the bathroom but it doesn't look
good for the cleanliness of his hands if
he weren't fully sold on carmichael
being an evil villain his questionable
hygiene habits surely push him over the
edge
recently retired donald fitzroy knows
all about lloyd hansen and his checkered
past with the cia lloyd was relieved of
his duties for things like bad ethics
zero impulse control and unsanctioned
torture which is somehow worse than
regular sanctioned torture but it looks
like all of those qualities ultimately
helped lloyd to become an entrepreneur
he's the guy the agency calls to do the
dirty work fitzroy makes a snide comment
about lloyd spending his time strangling
cats because the private sector doesn't
pay that well if you ever glanced at
chris evans instagram page you're
probably aware of his dog dodger and how
much he adores him but does that mean
that he's anti-cat in real life during a
2017 interview with parade evans
discussed his feline co-star in the film
gifted i'm not a cat person i respect
cats i think they're beautiful creatures
i just don't think they like me of
course evan's thoughts on cats are much
much milder than those of his grey man
character in reality the line in the
film has nothing to do with evans but
rather is a subtle reference to another
netflix original in a still watching
netflix interview the russo brothers
revealed that the line is meant as a nod
to the disturbing netflix documentary
don't with cats it's really a reference
to sociopathy
two years prior to the main story of the
gray man someone leaked fitzroy's
personal information which made his
niece claire a potential target at the
time margaret cahill was the bureau
chief so she had the authority to put
sierra 6 on security detail for claire
there's a brief scene of six fitzroy and
cahill discussing the assignment which
takes place in cahill's london office
during the scene cahill is shown sitting
at her desk smoking if you look closely
you can see two big boxes of lucky
strike cigarettes directly in front of
her on the desk jump ahead to the
movie's present day where we meet a
retired margaret and a slow pan of her
home reveals prescription medicine
bottles and an oxygen tank it's pretty
clear that cahill's heavy smoking
ultimately led to a struggle with cancer
and we're told that she only has three
months to live
when we first see sierra 6 in bangkok
he's sitting at a table in the middle of
a party he snacks on some hors d'oeuvres
and keeps the toothpick to chew on until
he's forced to chase down his target
throughout the film he can be seen doing
a lot of random snacking and sporadic
gum chewing when he enters the fitzroy
hong kong home he's immediately
chastised by claire by chewing gum since
it's her uncle who seems to have a
penchant for bubblicious it's not
entirely clear who made that rule it's
possible to read six's penchant for
snacking and chewing as a kind of oral
fixation an idea in freudian psychology
that's theoretically connected to
childhood neglect in the context of
fiction it can make for an interesting
character trait we don't get a lot of
backstory on six's childhood but we do
know that it was far from happy maybe
that has something to do with his love
of gum or maybe you just like snacking
there must be some perks to make the
whole cia thing worthwhile maybe one of
them is being able to travel anywhere at
the drop of a hat early in the gray man
agent miranda is in berlin being accused
of protecting six even though she barely
knows him while carmichael is suspending
her from field duty he gets a text that
six is in vienna being the skilled spy
that she is miranda reads the text in
the reflection of his glasses and forms
a plan right when six is about to get
shot by lloyd miranda saves the day by
hitting the assassin with a tranquilizer
dart at this point miranda is rogue
she's been suspended from field work and
surely her travel privileges have been
revoked sure berlin and vienna aren't
too far apart in the grand scheme of
things but it would still take at least
a few hours to make it all happen the
speed with which miranda arrives at
six's location is really only believable
if she walked out of carmichael's office
and right onto a plane the specifics of
her travel plan are some of the many
unanswered questions in the grey man but
it just seems a bit hard to imagine that
she'd end up in the exact right place at
the exact right time
lots of film lovers are excited by
cameos and the russo brothers are no
different in 2014 the duo directed
captain america the winter soldier and
they've noted on instagram that the
fight on the freeway is one of their
favorite fight sequences while working
with marvel it wasn't just the technical
nature of the sequence that made it a
favorite the fact that they snuck quite
a few friends and family members into
the scene may have played into that as
well joe russo himself has also managed
cameos in several different mcu films
this may now just be something to expect
from the director russo shows up at the
end of the grey man as well playing one
of the executive cia agents once all the
dust has settled russo's character can
be seen at a conference table telling
carmichael miranda and suzanne brewer
that he doesn't know how to defend their
actions russo told screenrant that the
main reason he keeps doing the cameos is
for his kids who are entertained by
seeing him pop up in the movies
you